brought to you by Final Fantasy 15
available on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
November 29th hey guys my name is Jess
and if you catch a lot of GS news
episodes you'll know I spend a lot of
time standing here but we just moved
into a new office so I thought why not
show you around with a little help from
my friends first up this week we were
treated to even more Mass Effect
Andromeda information so here's what
you'll be getting up to you when you're
not turn them bang your container you'll
be able to explore worlds with Andromeda
it's new ground vehicle the Nomad which
will literally cannot control worse than
the tanki Mako on most of those worlds
you'll encounter a Hogwarts and need to
take out enemy bases which are
apparently barely time intensive
endeavors you'll also happen upon giant
bosses and encounters that are way too
high level for you to take on right away
how will you know when an encounter is
going to be too tough
well Bioware says you'll know it when
you see it while you're running from
mopey baddies you can also scan areas
and objects and that info back to your
ship and subsequently craft weapons and
armor from your findings planets also
feature drop zones that function as fast
travel points and locations to tweak
your loadout although there's all this
trouble with Final Fantasy 5 - e15 got
leaked in south america spoilers it
everywhere and how'd you make the body
is super bombed ff15 is enjoy out until
november 29 the number of plates in
south america managed to get their hands
on a coffee early and have started live
streaming it like jerks game director an
all-around cool guy Hajime Tabata made a
statement saying we are very regretful
of the situation one of the major goals
for Final Fantasy 15 is for everyone to
enjoy the story and discover the
surprises together through the
simultaneous worldwide release due to
these recent events videos with
unexpected spoilers could potentially be
posted online so we would like to warn
everyone who has been waiting in
anticipation for this game another final
fantasy news 15 will reportedly be
getting a 7.2 gigabyte day one patch
which kind of sucks since a day one
patch was exactly what they were trying
to avoid when they delayed the game from
its original September release day
hello my name is Daniel crowd I am here
to talk to you about the financial
earnings of North American video game
retailer game stock Game Stop reported
that their third quarter earnings were
down 2.9 percent year-on-year which is
definitely not what they wanted and
their pre-owned game sales stood by six
point four percent they still made
almost two billion dollars though and
apparently sold a crapload of Pokemon
and five nights at freddys toys so
retail isn't quite dead yet in terms of
game and hardware sales they reported
that Call of Duty infinite warfare
underperformed this year rats they
didn't provide any specifics but that'll
probably be enough fuel for the
battlefield fanatics the ps4 Pro is
allegedly off to a strong start and psvr
units are also selling well only staying
on shelves for an average of 10 days
however overall hardware sales were down
for them by a whopping twenty point six
percent whackadoo and finally the
Pokemon Sun and Moon games have
apparently been the best selling games
for Game Stop all year with pre-orders
for Sun and Moon reaching the highest
number for any game at gamestop in five
years
where
this week Bethesda's Todd Howard said
he's keen on Nintendo's switch and calm
down of still gamer hearts like mine by
saying the Elvis troll six is coming
it's coming right he said it's coming so
it's got to come right if it's on the
way yeah okay
anyway Howard got his hands on the
switch and told glicks Allah I love it I
got to play it I will tell you well
maybe that's an NDA thing it's one of
the best demos I've ever seen probably
the best demo I've ever seen happy three
he confirmed bethesda would definitely
be supporting the console and with
Skyrim showing up in the switch reveal
trailer as a chance that could be on
there too but nothing's been confirmed
Howard did indeed confirm that Elder
Scrolls 6 is in the works but added it's
not what you would call a big active
project right now oh this games gonna be
years off isn't it let's talk about
something else are you still playing an
inferior version of Pokemon well if it's
any consolation they released like two
new things for this week
first up Niantic has expanded the new
Pokemon tracking feature to a wider user
base the tool will now show you images
of poke stops in your area and the
Pokemon that have been spotted near
there which removes some of the
guesswork and it has now been confirmed
that you can find and catch deter the
Pokemon with absolutely no personality
of its own
the catch is ditto mimics and appears as
other Pokemon out in the wild so we
won't know you have one until the 50th
Magic IV caught today turns into one and
finally Niantic is hosting a double xp
weekend as a thank you to the hundreds
of millions of players that means this
weekend you'll get double the XP and
Stardust and quadruple the XP if you
using lucky eggs that's all this week's
news and a look at our new offer if you
guys have been awesome Thanksgiving
weekend and we will catch you later